بشوفهم بالحلم
واحدان قلي ع بدي
ميه لا الجهان لحتى الرف عنهم اي حاجه انا
ما بعرفش عن اولاد
المعاك انا اسمي ميساء درويش كنا احنا
نازحين في مدرسه سعد بن ابي وقاص في
الصفطاوي اخذت اودي خذت جوزي ورحنا على
بير النعجه على دارنا على سبت اني ايش
اعجن لهم حبه حبه طحين واحمهم واغسل اوم
ونرجع على المدرسه ثاني مرقت كاره الله
يعزكم وحمار طلعنا على الكاره الا ما شفنا
الا صاروخ بنان بينزل على القاره والحمد
لله اولادي شويه اصابات يعني اجت فيهم
وانا اصابتي كانت في ظهري من الكتف للكتف
الحمد لله يعني اخذت 140 غرزه وكانت
عمليته صعبه كثير بعد اسبوع تحاصر
لاندونيسي
نعيم ابراهيم النجار جب ل البلد جب البلد
المنكوبه احنا طلعنا والقصف فوق رؤسنا
لقيت ان احنا بجي 50 يوم ه وطلعت انا عندي
اثنين معاقين عندي اثنين معاقين على
كراريس داوود ابني الكبير داوود متجوز مع
ولدين وبنتين ولد الثاني 21 سنه نص جوو
وطلعنا احنا من الفوف طلعنا وقال لنا يعني
الزلمه الحج الحج قال اطلعوا وانا بحكوا
يا حج بالكراريس بالاولاد فاحنا اجينا هنا
نستنى فيهم عندهم اجي عندهم اجي ما جو شي
ر مره قالوا لكم احنا مقس كمال عدوان بعد
ما تحسرت كمال عدوان
وشرفونا ما وين لحتى الان ماعرفش هم وين
نفسي بس اسمع نفسهم اللي يطمني انهم
عايشين كل يوم بقر جوالاته مسكره فيش فيش
سالفه لا يمكن الوصول جوال مسكر عندي ولد
اسمه جلال عمره 16 سنه طويل وعريض
واسمراني وعندي باسم برضك عمره 15 سنه
اشقر و وطويل وعريض وعندي بنتي تسنيم
عمرها 14 سنه ضعيفه وشقره
[موسيقى]
البنت
انامه درويش اشتكت يا اخوات كثير وبص
عنهم والله قلبي قلبي داب وان افكر فيهم
قلب مفطور فطر بس اني اسمع صوتهم اني اسمع
نفسهم يقولوا لي ياما احنا
عايشين لما انعد اليهود عننا على جبل
البلد رنينا على واحد جارنا
قريبنا يقول طلعوا اليهود عدت عليهم اخذت
منهم ناس اخوي وابن اخوي ولاد اخوي
والاولاد طلعوهم بالكراريس رامو في الشارع
وعدوا على ال نسوين نسوان يضربوهم حولوهم
على الشفاع المدارس وين الارقب قالنا ه
لحد من الصبح دائما بفكر بروحش عن بال بل
يعني اقول ايش صار استشهد
ايش اكل
شرب